you can almost see the particles
floating down here I have a feeling that
the air quality is totally fine fully
within acceptable levels you cannot sit
here and tell me that the air quality in
this room is the same or worse as out
there especially on the street
[Music]
hey what's up look who it is back the
baby daddy are you doing how's the
studio everything's still standing right
yeah how's your baby enjoying college
college is great well just thing about
grad school but you have to pay for
yourself
you know where's Jake probably the back
doors closed so I figured yeah they
don't really come out here much the air
in the back room is like the best air in
the city now well another cigar
Commissioner vector filters oh and it's
filtered yeah Jake is harvesting that
fresh seep in so you've got a site how's
it going or he just jars it and says it
off what about what about us and the
rabble you're fooling yourself why
living in a dictatorship so they're just
leaving you guys aren't here to fend for
yourselves it's fine see you guys just
spend all your time back here now
oh yeah 77 degrees you have the most
optimal temperature for thinking but
it's also got a built-in air filter and
the aroma in here is is perfectly
neutral it's mine we put the air back in
sanctuary
you know there's fine out there I mean
don't you guys think it might be a
little more efficient if you guys out in
the front
throws to the team you go look man we've
been down here making videos for 10
years if you guys are new to this
channel by the way we've been doing this
for a little bit and there's some great
videos on these channels my point is
we've been down here for 10 years
sucking in that street juice air out
there and it cannot be good for you you
cannot sit here and tell me that the air
quality in this room is the same or
worse as out there especially on the
street playing hacky sack they're just
pretending to play hacky sack are they
dancing I mean Sam you used to live down
here yeah and I moved yeah
I don't think it's worth risking our
health till I seen your healthy
out there it's like smoking you have
that one cigarette every day about after
two weeks you're fine but after ten
years
I'm sure the air quality in this room is
prized actually I would bet you two air
quality in this room is worse than air
quality in the front this is no
ventilation in here no there's no
there's just no way that that's true we
have an airfield there go those are you
willing to bet if I can show you guys
the air quality in the front of the
studio it's totally like on par with
like health standards will you not hold
yourselves up back here in this nice
little cave I mean it's like betting on
the bangles to win the Super Bowl this
year it's just not gonna happen
let me bet you if you're wrong you'll
come back into the sanctuary
alright just stare out the glass I've
been playing at God they gotta get back
to work yeah a Christian new bias like a
medium quality air tester sure I've
never bought one of those before but I
think we can find one it alone how often
do you think about the air that you
breathe it's hard I'd barely even think
about breathing so again do you ever
think about the air quality Oh someone
the other things to worry about
constantly every day when I went to
Illinois how much feces air am i
breathing
how much diesel seemed in my
I'm thinking about the air quality all
the time and that's how you why have
asked me not being able to breathe sucks
it's not something that like bothers me
day to day so I don't worry about in
that context but obviously it'd be nice
to have better air Los Angeles won the
title of the smokiest American city 19
of the last 20 years that fresh fresh we
dare more weed in the air it's hard
issues up here see all the air
conditioners over there on that building
all the air conditioners right there
everywhere that's weed anytime there's a
warehouse with a ton of air conditioners
on the top it's all weed growing see
those buildings down there that's
downtown LA 30 years ago you would've
been able to see it through the smog
things have gotten ate a lot better than
you do I'm not a dum-dum I'm not gonna
try to argue that car emissions are
great and staying next to highway is
great but I'm gonna say that in our
studio all the vents are blocked and I
have a feeling that the air quality is
totally fine totally within acceptable
levels I kind of feel like it's all the
same
so I saw a tweet from Hank green the
other day saying hey if you feel bad
about your life don't because I just
bought don't pair of Haley's and I was
inspired I was like you know what I will
too
here I am a dirty old man with Healy's
you see this is what happens when Jake
doesn't sit out in the main room anymore
Oh big so we have this air tester here
and what this test for is particulate in
the air a test for very fine particulate
which can be inhaled into your lungs and
cause lung damage and heavier
particulate like actual grains of dust
and sand basically when you dust your
shelves that's the pm10 level
particulate PM 2.5 is very very fine
dust and that's a little more dangerous
for you because it doesn't get caught by
your body's mucus and hair and all that
kind of stuff that exists to filter the
air now LA used to be a very smoggy
place and smog was a combination of like
sulfur dioxide carbon dioxide carbon
monoxide but as well as smoke and smoke
is particulate from power planes burning
coal from car emissions and that created
this thick layer that would sit in the
air and there's equipment like smoking
like four packs of cigarettes a day and
that was back in the early 90s late 80s
and since then they have heavily
regulated smog with cause this is not
going to test for chemicals this is not
going to test for ozone sulfur dioxide
co2 any of that kind of stuff it's just
gonna test for particulate but generally
speaking I think it's safe to say that
if the particulate is really low
probably not getting too much chemicals
with it disclaimer in this video we're
testing for particulate Classics mark
what is good air what are the numbers PM
2.5 it is acceptable anything below 12 I
guess is good there's no way we're going
to wear clothes well down here or 55 and
up is bad well that's unhealthy I don't
think we want healthy for sensitive
groups includes like our children in
your baby anything above 12 is bent it
has to be good and that's it period what
do you think has the cleanest air in the
world America not too bad we always
didn't know
in the middle of this fire that's
happening pm10 is at 776 in the 2.5 s at
500 which is awful awful so it can spike
drastically don't see the heavy stuff
let's take it the Beijing oh my gosh
dude this is why all the stuff you get
an Amazon is so cheap is because there's
no environmental regulations in China
there is no way twelve or less I would
expect it to be somewhere around 100 I
think it's that 40 or 50 but who knows
you know air quality can change very
rapidly depending on where you are the
guys are obviously out testing the air
today I thought we'd go ahead and test
the flavors of today's sponsor hella
fresh because that's how it works so
today we are making some pork tacos pork
carnitas pops I've actually been a
subscriber to hella fresh for almost a
year now and this is the first time we
sponsored before they do several things
that really help streamline the cooking
process obviously for one they deliver
all the ingredients to you in one box
that's really convenient I don't like
shopping for groceries
secondly I like the variety every week
there are new meals and you get to
choose whatever meals you want like
there's burgers every week just tacos
every week there's like pastas every
week or vegetarian options - if you want
you're making a meal using fresh
ingredients that they gave you like
these are actual tomatoes that
Christians literally just sliced up and
onions and blah no pepper a lime limes
oh and on top of that it's flexible
enough if you decide to not have meals
next week and you just like put a pause
on it like I went on vacation for a
couple weeks I just put a pause in like
the meals that I had for like two
straight weeks I was able to resume it
again when I got back probably the thing
that has helped me most from hella fresh
is I didn't know how to cook my wife
loves cooking and so she always makes
our meals at home cuz she enjoys it she
transfer from the night shift to day
shift as a nurse and now suddenly she's
working all day so I got to make meals I
learned how to cook from I'm not even
kidding I learned how to cook from
hellofresh because they have like these
instructions they're super simple to
follow now that I've been doing this for
like so many months I actually feel
fairly confident with like my cooking
skills in general like I can whip stuff
up I'm even altering ingredients
sometimes just based off of my own
experience I am curious whether or not
the particulates that are being cooked
and thrown up into the air will even
register here like so many flavors
there's the numbers going down oh no
it's bite is that over 100 look at that
180 flairs is that a lot of flavor we'll
ask yourself this flavor is 90% smell
aka aromas so most of what you taste is
what's already in the air 325 it's about
to break a thousand I'm not putting it
in me you basically our prices for hella
fresh start just now at 566 per serving
get started today with eight free meals
and that's eighty dollars off your first
month of hellofresh go to hello fresh
comm and enter the promo code corridor
crew 80 well evidently this is testing
way too many flavors for us to really
see if this is good or not we have to
use our mouths Bon Appetite
oh just got that bite got that Chipotle
but hmm let's gonna see if Jake and Sam
have feelings or facts good went on in
their hearts so we're gonna go under the
highway we're gonna go closest to the
highway possible and we're gonna measure
the air quality there this is basically
where we feeling the portal trick shots
where aim bot was filmed will you show
the million things right here under the
street that question is did we tell
ourselves slowly getting cancer there
let's go find out you can almost see the
particles floating down here
yeah look we go the highway just
I'm gonna say 99 100
I don't get it I mean the air is
definitely cleaner than it has been in
weeks right now I can like literally
smell like exhaust and fumes and stuff
here fumes is not the same as a reading
here but particulate necessarily let's
go over by the edge of under Street I
was a little higher now actually I'm
heading getting getting readings of five
five point six right here practically
unbreathable here right now look this is
points it's horrible like my throat is
burning right now from breathing out
here two point three you don't need to
be a scientist to stand on the street
corner and and know that the air quality
is bad so I'm just a little I'm a little
confused I don't believe that any of
this here's guys a cigarette
Jemaine exhaling smoke into this air
detector we want to see if it's actually
working
yes it just jumped up to 157 it works it
works 400 a pm10 is over 600 we can say
smoking is bad for you air purifier Jake
listen should we just go test the back
room should we just finish this we're
gonna go on the roof of the studio next
to see if the air quality up there is
any different except put us on the level
of the highway normally you can't see
those mountains
that's the dets the difference between
right now and it's always clear in the
fall like this well you know the weather
in the studio doesn't really change all
right here we go a science bringing in
the Sun we got oh my god
1.5
moving the air quality our studio is
worse than outside does that mean you
got your status on the roof here it's
pretty good chance it's gonna be worse
inside that now that I started thinking
about this critically alright let's test
the air collide in the studio no one
contaminate the air everyone hold it in
three three it's worse than here that it
is outside right now saying three
doesn't mean anything per meter squared
Z 2.5 for micrometers it's now let's see
what kind of ppm is a smoker 15 H dude
66 the ultimate test is the safe air
sanctuaries everything it's cracked up
to be
here we go 3i it's like you're telling
me that like blue is red and red is
green like I'm just like but I was there
under the freeway and it smelled like
subscribe maybe it's all those things
that aren't particulate but I don't
think it's as bad for you as particles
the air quality in LA it's rare days
like this where you can actually see
downtown clearly if you came back and
you measured this on a smoggy day you'd
see readings at least 10 times as high
as we're seeing today when we look at
the official readings for an area it's a
lot higher PM 2.5 for this area is
technically an a20 2.5 according to the
state's equipment
knows why it's different from what we're
reading that's what it says and it says
generally la is kind of in that same
area I think the big takeaway here is
you all got to get on the backroom and
hang out on the floor all your boys
because we're all here reading the same
era together Nico you feel like you've
proved it to me like I should move out
into the main area here but I think we
need to strongly consider a little bit
more data before anyone makes any
serious decisions like moving away from
the sanctuary air quality is subjective
and you should just let us live our
lives in peace it wasn't as bad in LA as
I thought for particulate or didn't
measure chemicals
definitely that's something but at the
same time it's like particulate so low
and here I can't imagine there's any
like higher concentration of chemicals I
will say however that looking at the
rest of the world really opened my eyes
and how bad things can get and that we
are very lucky that we have the economic
resources and the regulations out here
to keep the air somewhat clean because
back thirty years ago it was really bad
in LA it was just like Beijing so
hopefully in time Beijing and the area's
over in China or India or anywhere else
that has crappy air hopefully in time
that can improve so as Jake pointed out
it's actually a very nice day outside
the fact that rain this weekend which
actually takes all the particulate out
of the air in LA and takes time for the
cars and everything to kick that back up
so we're going to continue taking
readings and if you want to see if we're
all slowly getting lung cancer follow us
on instagram at corridor digital meal
post readings every once in a while it's
also a link in the description below for
your convenience thanks for watching
don't forget to subscribe it's hovering
at 11:00 now
it's skyrocketing at our 3d printers
matters the dust 4472 Edie I don't want
to be in here anymore it stopped at 87th
and the pm10 is about to Berko hundred
have fun with your peepee
[Applause]